if you're a kid out there that feels
like
maybe you're broken somehow like
the world be better off without you in
it
i promise you
it's the world that's broken not you
hey guys pete here
today i'll be talking about for all
mankind season 3 episode 6 which slowed
things down some but i don't think it
was necessarily a bad thing and knew
eden the race to get to mars is over and
now everyone is facing brand new
challenges trying to survive while they
try and fail to play nice with each
other larry may be shooting up the
charts to overtake danny as the
character that fans are the most angry
at but i don't know danny doesn't look
like he'll go down without a fight this
episode also emphasizes the fact that
just because things are more optimistic
in this timeline continuing the space
race doesn't result in a utopia this
reality is still filled with humans and
all that goes along with that i'll be
getting into everything that happened
and what i think about it right after i
tell you that this video will contain
spoilers if you haven't watched the
sixth episode of for all mankind's third
season yet then this video won't be for
you and with that out of the way let's
get into it
any landing you can walk away from is a
good one we heard neil armstrong say the
same thing back in season one when he
was the first american to land on the
moon danielle saying it on mars is a
nice touch that brings up memories of
all that's been accomplished in this
alternate timeline but also made me
consider how different the situation
they're encountering on the red planet
is i think they did a good job of doing
that with the music too it reminded me
of the old westerns and when you add
some atmosphere and some color this
doesn't feel anything like the moon 30
years after nasa lost that their
unplanned joint mission with ross cosmos
did get to mars first but the decision
to make the low visibility landing cost
them their ship we watch as ed and danny
bring the helios lander down for second
place and the unceremonious way they
plant their flag and the look on ed's
face does a great job to show you how
they feel about it there's a nice little
news section that lays out all of what's
happening now that the race is over even
though it was technically a tie the us
news considers it a win for the country
because it was their ship that got them
there now there's a race to find water
and helios has located some small
deposits which is enough for them to
start manufacturing their methane fuel
this is now in everyone's interest with
sojourner grounded phoenix will be
everyone's ride back to earth and they
need that methane since nasa uses
different fuel trying to cram eight
people into a hab with only enough
provisions for six makes things
difficult for the joint mission they
need to find water create their own
oxygen set up their nuclear power
generator grow their own food and even
though this all looks inspiring from
back on earth tensions are building
between the two crews fast it's cramped
hot they're rationing water and the
soviet commander seems committed to
challenging danielle every chance he
gets the one place where there's the
opposite of tension is between kelly and
alexei but that seems like it's probably
gonna cause some real problems later
things are going a little smoother at
heliospace but danny is still watching
ed's messages to karen he finds out that
he was the reason that ed decided to
abort their landing and that makes
things even more uncomfortable between
them as much as i haven't been enjoying
this story i do like how charged this
revelation is it stings because they
could have been first if ed had seen him
as a regular astronaut and now danny's
hearing that this guy who he resents
because of karen thinks of him as a son
this works a little better than danny
just wanting to be with karen and ed is
actively making things worse because
he's trying to do what he did with gordo
you can understand why ed is doing it
but we also know that it's a mistake we
see things start to bubble up when he
hurts his hand he gets an attitude when
ed tries to show concern and he gets his
hands on some tylenol with codeine that
we'll talk about again in a minute
in other not going to end well
developments margot contacts general
bradford about getting sergey's family
out in exchange for his defection she
doesn't mention him by name but assures
the now chairman of the joint chiefs
that he'll be a valuable asset to nasa
the mention of black ops makes this
sound like a very bad idea but i guess
it does make sense given her position i
don't love that it continues to be hard
to see how she gets out of this in fact
i really don't see it happening and i
also didn't love to see karen go back to
helios at first we do find out that that
was all set in motion by ross cosmos
reaching out to her and since it was
satisfying to see her turn the table
some on dev i guess that might turn out
alright i just don't see how her wanting
to start things from the ground up and
being good at it fits in here also i
don't know where it's heading but
they've been quietly introducing debs
partner richard hilliard last episode we
saw him looking at dev and mission
control after they aborted the landing
and here we see that there are some
tensions between them because mars is
costing so much money you get to know
the people at happy valley base through
a series of tv interviews they're
recording things get interesting when
will who's been inspired by their
monumental achievement comes out as gay
i think this works pretty well in that i
can see why he did it when he explains
his timing to danielle it absolutely
makes sense from his perspective plus
it's nice to see someone who's awed by
this experience of a brand new world at
the same time it creates problems so
when danielle doesn't react the way
you'd hoped she would that makes sense
too where it gets ugly is with his old
pal roland the soviet defector from last
season who he's been training with for
the last couple of years they've grown
close and now he doesn't want anything
to do with him he goes as far as going
to danielle and trying to get reassigned
which i don't know how he thought that
might turn out considering how many
people are there it's not necessarily
surprising to see someone have such a
negative reaction to homosexuality it's
ridiculous but there are a lot of
backward people out there ellen even
reminds us in this episode about deke's
negative reaction in season one it also
wasn't out of the ordinary for people to
be irrationally afraid of aids in the
early years though in our timeline it
seems like by 94 that wouldn't fly
danielle tells him that they all had hiv
tests on earth before they left but
doesn't say and besides you can't get
aids just by being next to someone i'm
not sure if the show is trying to point
out something about roland or if it's
trying to say that progress on people
knowing about aids is slower in this
reality either way his reaction is rough
to watch and will's announcement puts
ellen in a very difficult spot on the
one hand ellen and larry understand what
a psychological toll staying in the
closet can take on a person on the other
doing that has made it possible for them
to become the most powerful couple in
the world i suppose the show has made
the point that this power has its limits
and we see larry come up with a version
of don't ask don't tell to temporarily
solve their problem at the cost of it
not helping will at all knowing that
he'll be discharged from the army when
he returns what she calls uniforms first
is not a perfect solution in any
timeline but it does work for her
politically in this one on a personal
level it's not clear how she'll live
with the decision but that seems primed
to take a back seat to the other
incoming scandal that we learn about at
the end
karen helps the broker a deal with roz
cosmos who've discovered a large deposit
of liquid water the show never explains
why they were able to find this and nasa
wasn't but i guess we're just supposed
to accept that it sets up a situation
where helios and the soviets team up
behind nasa's back because ed is the one
who can get them there by helping them
helios will also benefit from this huge
discovery sergey comes through to tip
margot off about what's going on it's a
cute scene where at first i thought he
was betraying her installing a listening
device or something like that but it
turns out that he leaves an equation on
her record when she solves it she knows
what the secret mission is about and she
goes and tells elena she goes straight
to tell danielle which seemed a little
impulsive they had shown that she was
suspicious of the soviets in mission
control because of what she knows about
the engine but it was still a little
surprising that she just exposed what
they were doing like that i'm not sure
if this will come up again later but i
thought it was worth mentioning danielle
tells everyone else after ed's
well-intentioned thanksgiving party
turns into a brawl which i guess that
always happens no matter where you have
one of these things will finally calls
out roland for acting weird around him
and they do fight danielle finally lets
the soviet commander know what she
thinks and everyone in her crew is
pissed about the water ed tries to
smooth things over with kelly and she
talks him into bringing her along
because she thinks there's a good chance
there might be life in that water also
when he goes back to his hab he sends a
message to karen telling her that he's
worried about danny which of course gets
intercepted so danny has burnt through
his tylenol with codeine and he's gone
back and got some stronger oxycodone and
a little bit of speed to go along with
it they had a conversation where ed told
him that he would change the medical
protocol so he could stay on the planet
and this is another example of him
bending the rules so he can try to
recreate what he did with gordo when
he's talking to karen he tells her that
he's worried and you can imagine how
that might sit with the now loaded to
the gills danny who when he hears that
he thinks that he might not be cut out
for this starts punching the screen the
episode ends with ellen announcing her
new policy she confirms that it's too
late to help will in his situation on
the news you see it goes too far for
republicans and not far enough for
democrats which is something that they
expected larry's assistant is at a bar
talking to another gay friend or at
least someone pretending to be a friend
about this new policy and his
relationship with the first gentleman he
mentions that they've had relations in
the oval office that bring to mind the
real world monica lewinsky scandal on
his way out the friend gets a call and
tells the person on the other end that
he has to meet him in person to tell him
what he just found out it's not entirely
clear if it's his intention but it looks
like he'll end up exposing larry's
secret and that would put ellen in an
even tougher situation this was another
good episode character-wise it was great
will went from being the guy who was in
the right seat after the disaster to
someone who might turn out to be a
long-running character you care about it
will depend on what happens in the next
two years but i thought the actor did a
great job and really appreciated the
conversation he had with danielle even
though no one was satisfied in the end i
like that she says that reconstructing
the moral fabric of the universe is not
our mission when it might turn out doing
that anyway as i mentioned while i was
going through these things there were a
couple of details in the plot i didn't
think added up it wasn't enough to take
me out of it but i didn't find it as
easy to overlook these things as i think
they wanted us to we'll see how it all
plays out though the danny and ed thing
got a little more complicated but i feel
like they've passed the point where they
really have to come up with something
great to make it seem worth it after
dragging it out this long if the payoff
falls flat that'll be a big
disappointment i think it's clear larry
is going to be exposed but it kind of
makes my head spin when i try to think
of where it goes from there they're
obviously pulling from real world events
and bill clinton did survive his scandal
but this is a totally different case
based on her party affiliation i mean
right now we don't know of anything that
would make her lose the office but she
would become as powerless as it's
possible for a president to be and if
her vp's reaction to will is any
indication her party will be asking her
to resign what i liked about the episode
is it gave you a lot to think about and
it really drove home that idea that
everyone should be focused on what's
going on the struggle for survival the
opportunity to make something different
but that's not often how things really
work so i'm looking forward to see where
we go next and i think that's a good
place to leave things in the comments
tell me what you thought about new eden
and what you're hoping to see next week
please like this video if you enjoyed it
please subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already and thanks for watching
i'll talk to you soon